[Music]
nick is with us in indianapolis hey nick
how are you
i'm great dave but it's honored to speak
with you and ken as well i've been
listening to you for years and years
sure what's up
okay um
your phone is all scratchy and bad and
ugly can you make it pretty
hello you hear me better now uh a little
bit let's try it
okay um
i've went through a lot uh
in the past few years um
i have
went through a divorce and lost both my
parents all within
five years or so
i'm
i have a
criminal record i have a dui on my
record and
other possession charges i was a heroin
addict for five years after my parents
died
and uh
i've been two years sober now good for
you yeah i've i've i'm having a hard
time budgeting because
i don't make enough money i make half of
what i used to and
it just feels like i'm barely surviving
on what i make what are you doing right
now what are you doing for work
i'm not a mechanic
i i went to trade school right out of
right out of high school and uh
auto mechanic or what
yeah auto mechanic at a dealership i i
used to be you know for uh
and then i went to school you got you
you got your driver's license back after
the dui
yeah okay so you're driving you just
have a record and you've been drive for
three you've been dry off the heroin for
three years
yeah and the
the insurance companies at the
dealership they won't they won't accept
any duis within like 10 years so
i have to work at a private you know
like a little
small lot and they don't pay as well and
other things what are you making right
now per hour as a mechanic
twenty dollars an hour okay
what could you make
let's yeah what could you make if you
didn't have any of these record issues
what would the rate be that you would
expect to make
40.
okay so the insurance the insurance
at the dealership is to ensure what
your health insurance
no the
so
like the uh
the
insurance the dealership has to ensure
me to drive all the customers cars
just the liability that they have for me
to drive i got you okay how long ago was
the dui
um three years ago okay how long before
it drops off on this issue
they said that they can go back 10 years
i think it might be seven but they said
10. okay all right so we know we're
dealing basically i'm trying to
yeah i'm trying to make it by until then
and then i'll have you know i'll be fine
after that no i don't want you to make a
battle then i want you to go beat the
system we got to figure this out yeah so
the gap here is
you're making 20 an hour and you're
barely making ends meet making 20 an
hour so we've got some financial stuff
we got to look at and then we need to
look at professionally where else can i
work as a mechanic and outside of a
dealer you know i go to a local mechanic
stacie and i take our cars to a guy and
they're not a big corporation
small business and
you know i think there's some some good
people out there
that probably have enough work going
around to where you could find a much
better paying mechanic job than just a
really small shop i at least want to
challenge you on that to look for that
and consider that and i will just tell
you this quickly because i want dave to
address some of the financial stuff on
why you're not making ends meet and what
we can do there but i want to challenge
this this premise that
all people are going to judge you
because of your legal past a lot of
people do and it's unfortunate but the
reality is is that through relationships
in your local community there are enough
people that know who you are who you
were
and who you are and how you've been
clean and how you're making a better
path and it's through relationships
that you will get opportunities because
as a mechanic right now this is a
wonderful time you can make a lot more
money than you're making right now even
if you take on a side hustle i i think
you can get back in the 40 range without
working for a dealer i think you're
gonna get back with other mechanical
things so let me let me ask you that how
old are you
34. how long ago was the divorce
uh three years
okay
all right
so what i'm hearing is dui and dry and
divorce all the three year mark that was
the bottom wasn't it
yeah that was the bottom
i i my parents died in
15 2015 like
uh two years apart and then i was
basically spiraling down since
2015. let me uh let me throw a guess at
you
i was 28
when i lost everything i went bankrupt
and it was my fault
the reason i went bankrupt is i was
stupid
and i signed a whole bunch of short-term
notes
and so after i went bankrupt i had to
recover financially but i also lost my
confidence
for a period of time
and then i started handling money god's
ways biblically common sense ways and i
started gradually rebuilding my
confidence but part of the process for
me
becoming valuable again in the
marketplace was to first forgive myself
and get over my past because i was
pretty stinking ashamed
and i kind of think that's holding you
back more than the actual marketplace is
holding you back
i think you're a stud i feel like i
deserve to make less because exactly
because you lost your family you're
heroin you lost your mom and dad you had
a dui and this is your this is your
punishment well son your punishment's
over yeah
as of today
you're no longer being punished
you're a stud listen dude anybody kicks
heroin is a superman
that is a tough one to bust
that's a tough one
that's no light weight
that's not vaping okay i mean that's
serious crap
so you are a stud and you are coming
back
and you are worth forty dollars an hour
because you can work on a car as good or
better than the other dubers that are
doing it for forty dollars an hour
you may not be able to do the test drive
around the block you might have to pay
the guys next to you 50 bucks a week to
do your test drives for you and you sit
in the passenger seat and listen to the
symptom then you go back and turn the
wrench i don't know there's a way to
skin this cat though dude but it starts
with you saying all of the crap is in
the rear view mirror and it's smaller
than the windshield because it doesn't
count as much
you're worth this man you can do i'm
trying to get
side hustles and stuff and uh you know
side work you know fixing cars for
people but you know because of all my
trouble you know my circle you know as
you know i don't have nick nick listen
expand your circle you just agree with
what dave said now act on it you believe
what he said now act on it expand your
circle go out right now the people that
do believe in you
ask for opportunity start fixing stuff
on the side anywhere and everywhere you
can you need to you need to have people
that when they look over on the across
your back they see a superman cape yeah
because that's who i see
you can do this young man you can do
this
and and i i understand i've had those
exact same feelings for different
reasons but i had those exact same
feelings and i became valuable when i
started believing i was valuable again